et en tunisie à présent la situation
sanitaire est très préoccupante est le
nombre de nouveaux cas de kovy des deux
décès atteint un niveau record dans le
pays est la correspondance de ben hassen
chébili à tunis en tunisie la situation
sanitaire est inquiétante et face à
l'accélération de l'épidémie le
gouvernement a annoncé de nouvelles
restrictions à partir du 1er juillet
jusqu'au 14 juillet pour le grand tunis
il est ville de monastir et de sousse à
partir du 1er juillet tous les
événements culturels sont interdits
fermeture des mosquées des hammams des
salles de sport les événements privés
est également interdite fermeture de
toutes les terrasses des restaurants des
cafés et des bars à partir de 16h
interdiction d'entrer et de sortir du
territoire du grand tunis alors que six
gouvernorats déjà sont en confinement
total
l'armée a même été appelé en renfort
pour respecter ce confinement notamment
dans les villes de béjaois encore barry
ville de sylviane a de son côté le
comité scientifique avait préconisé un
confinement total de l'ensemble du
territoire pour une durée de six
semaines
impossible au vu du contexte économique
en tunisie actuelle la raison pour
laquelle le gouvernement a opté pour ces
nouvelles restrictions
la vaccination de ce côté a du mal à se
mettre en place sur l'ensemble du
territoire seulement 1,8 million de
tunisiens sont vaccinés sont les 12
millions que compte le pays 13% de la
population a déjà reçu une première dose
5% seulement une seconde dose le
gouvernement tunisien continue ses
partenariats avec les pays producteurs
de vaccins 500000 vaccins sont arrivés à
être déjà sur le territoire de la chine
et puis on attend pour le courant du
mois d'août 2 millions de doses du
vaccin
johnson & johnson selon le m s la
vaccination en tunisie ne suffit pas le
gouvernement doit accélérer sa campagne
de prévention et le respect les gestes
barrière la tunisie qui compte un bilan
humain des plus lourds sur l'ensemble du
maghreb
et puis de l'afrique une situation qui
inquiète notamment le secteur
touristique se prépare à ouvrir et la
peur de revivre exactement la même
situation que l'an dernier il faut
savoir que 10 % des actifs en tunisie
vivent du tourisme une situation
inquiétante alors que le monde hôtelier
essaie de se préparer un maximum avec
notamment des protocoles sanitaires
assez strict un enjeu immense
ce pour la tunisie alors que la saison
touristique vient d'ouvrir